we then saw after that we saw a very
good demo or a very short trailer for
what been students were working on which
we did again talk in the pre-show days
gone we saw a trailer Fred and then at
the end of the show I mean pretty good
for a showstopper we saw a gameplay of
it Alexa what did you think of that well
you before we went on air you said all
hyper dead rising the high zhengzhou
they hijack did this incredible I mean
it's a different type of zombie game you
know we again at the pre-show we were
talking about zombie games and saying
like you know if eventually somebody has
to do something different a dead rising
was something different back in whatever
was 2007 or so and and the new ones are
obviously like evoking that as well but
like in this you know I daresay
realistic but it more grounded in
realism in terms of the combat at least
like he spends most of his time at the
end of this demo fleeing a massive horde
of zombies yeah Peter what did you think
of this bad boy I was very impressed by
how the the series of events just sort
of chained together and how well you
know one minute it's kind of common
serene and it wasn't like he was
entering an area where it was like okay
this is Ombey time like it just it all
seemed to happen just very organically
and unfold in a way that was a surprise
to not only us but obviously the
character as well yeah zareen what did
you think so when they first showed the
trailer at the beginning of the
girlfriends I wasn't sold I thought the
dialogue was a bit cheesy in kind of
week and it was just like another oh
it's another person [ __ ] elliptic and I
a zombie game whatever and I wasn't you
know like I was like I guess that looks
kind of interesting yes but then they
showed all the gameplay and I was like
whoa like you're tackling a massive
hoard you know it all kind of escalates
really quickly I'm really interested to
see what else like the game lets you do
I'm interested to see how open it is as
well because when zombie games we almost
sort of by default consider them to be
open world because so many of them are
right early sort of in large areas and
this one with like you know there was a
very sort of direct connection between
you know grabbing that muffler out of
the car and then using it as a silencer
exact and then you know the way it sort
of escalated was quite you know since I
was some sort of linearity to this but
they've masted really well yeah so I
wonder if that's the overall game is
this could very much
to be like the last of us then again
that is you know very very scripted I
mean even so this look too impressive
yeah the hoarder here was tremendous to
the came out of knowing yeah incredible
like technically impressive is that it
even looked good before any of the sort
of the population went up as well like
even at the start I sort of remember
marking on it he just let that guy get
be didn't even finish them off
disgusting yeah let's let this play on
because I just I'd want to see this no
its nails target piling up and like when
my like a wave I like when the bridge
collapses under that way right section
where they're like inside that warehouse
where the bridge kind of just collapsed
and fell through like under all that way
and I thought well that mean just like
this I love that was using the gun
almost too just like stem the tide yeah
like not to stop a bit just to be like
mo there it's just like he's pulling it
out of nowhere yeah he's like you know
eventually they'll all be dead I just
need to do like ten percent of the work
every single time I turn around that's
genuinely terrifying that wave all right
zombies is genuinely terrified and the
sound because I had I had the the
conference audio piped into my ear and
it was just like screaming or like
constant level of screaming the entire
way through this demo I mean this bit
here is just this is just awful like how
unbelievably terrifying getting
animation there Peter it's pretty
impressive looking right it is very good
yeah and just to see how they all run on
top of each other in tumble and it right
it's it's incredible that this is a live
demo because the moment I started
watching I'm thinking like that doesn't
how can I look this good right then of
course they've got those windows over
there to prove me wrong like this is
this is very impressive yeah
unbelievable Wow he almost gets away
with it as well fairplay mesh like even
coming up top of the ceiling this one
zombie just hanging out in that roof
waiting first time ah yeah I mean who
knows like it'll be interesting I think
a lot of people going to eyes on this
immediately kind of like horizon zero
dawn last year we're certainly girl ever
getting inundated with requests it'll be
raining to see if this is a game that's
you know a bit more because the way he's
controlling seems open world or seems
like a game that gives you that I don't
know it's it's not like just cons it's
not like the camera is very scripted it
kind of feels like or very tight it
feels like it's giving you a certain
amount of a freedom and here's where it
all goes wrong
right dear friend i also got a wet lost
and damned vy bad but with the right i
mean alexa did say literally before the
show that it was a zombie biker game
zombies is motorcy so hey you were not
wrong look at this nonsense we probably
talk about another game but just look at
this Nazi I don't know it's like I was
really high for dead rising for and then
this happened and I was like okay yeah
Dead Rising would change of pace you
look at this this is just dumb I
expected the bridge to collapse here to
actually I just want Bridget I love this
thursday look like tumbling over each
other and just like falling like that so
that guy so division what is remain do
they always remain that's what I want to
know like there's still the buddies stay
there whole time yeah you dilute them
all one by one hold square over every
single I those guys yet Jesus
unbelieving at all those zombies
ridiculous